General Motors financial restructuring
plan it's getting a thumbs-up from Wall
Street this morning but a bad review
from the White House GM could layoff up
to 14,000 workers including 15 percent
of its salaried employees the auto
industry giant will stop production at
five of its factories in Michigan Ohio
Maryland Ontario Canada luxury and
compact sedans that had sluggish sales
including the Cadillac ct-6 and the
Chevy Cruze will be discontinued the
Cruze was the only car built at the GM
plant in Warren Ohio in July of last
year President Trump told GM workers in
Ohio not to move because all the jobs
would be back he said yesterday he told
GM CEO Mary Barra that he was upset
about the decision hours later at a
rally in Mississippi the president still
talked about creating hundreds of
thousands of manufacturing jobs during
his administration the previous
administration said all manufacturing
jobs that'll never happen I kept saying
what's he talking about manufacturing we
got to make things right
they said manufacturing jobs would never
come back you'd need a magic wand well
we found the magic wand in a statement
Barra said the decision helps GM be
highly agile resilient and profitable
while giving the company flexibility to
invest in the future Lea Gallagher's
Fortune magazine senior editor at large
and joins us more for more on this Lisa
helped explain this revenue is up at GM
they've had a huge windfall from the
president's tax cut and yet these huge
layoffs why yeah well there's three
major things that the car industry and
GM are facing one is car sales are
slowing that is a shift after many years
of the past three years in particular
they've really searched but there's
changes afoot the second thing is we
don't like sedans anymore Ward or
passenger cars are going out the window
with such a degree that it's even taken
the car industry by surprise if you look
at sit with what's replacing them guess
what is sales of SUVs look at the roads
around you they're everywhere and if you
look at the chart sedans are going like
this and SUVs are it's like a giant X
and so that GM is chock-full of sedans
so it is readjusting for the future so
that's a second thing and then the third
thing is that
it is really talking about the future
you know the future is autonomous cars
and self-driving and electric cars and
that stuff costs a lot of money that is
where things are going GM and Ford have
been such they epitomize the changes
that are happening in our economy where
tech is changing everything and they're
trying to not get left behind but
actually try to lead this and that is
gonna take a tremendous pivot and so
they've already been doing a lot with
that but this the Mary Barra is saying
we are gonna need to do a lot more so
they're gonna pour money into that you
know what Lee it's tough to see the the
agony on the workers face when they're
talking about losing their jobs but I'm
thinking about what Mary Barra must be
thinking right now is there a way to
look at it another way that perhaps she
is in fact saving the company definitely
and I think that's why you saw the
reaction from Wall Street
I'm the stocks went oh the stock went up
and a lot of analysts say that this is
something that is overdue at GM this
kind of restructuring but yes she is she
is taking the time right now when things
haven't really fallen yet you know
things are not dramatic yet but you know
she sees where the trends are going and
she said in in the statement that she's
you know good you're gonna try to make
these moves while things are still going
well to sustain us should there be a
downturn and to you know help take us
into the future so absolutely I mean you
know it's it's hard for these workers
but this is what's happening in so many
industries this is why we talk so much
about the need to rescale workers with
the jobs for the future are not the jobs
that we have had forever the changes are
so rapid and so significant to so many
industries and there's a tension between
politicians who say nothing's gonna
change we'll protect what you have in
business choices which are about the
future which sometimes caused this churn
but in you talk about retraining in this
case it looks like they want to hire
coders for these new electric cars sure
why not reach or can you retrain well
that's a good question
you can the interesting thing is a lot
of these are salaried workers so
designers product developers and and you
know those people may be able to find
you know there's always gonna be a
market for designers I would I would
think on the coding side you could do
the Ries killing some of this involves
AI which is a whole thing in in and unto
itself
and there are people in school right now
who are just studying AI and this is
going to be maybe the past for them do I
think there is some rescaling that's
possible but it's not for everyone did
the president's terrorist make a
difference here yes they did in fact so
they raised the cost of raw materials
that GM needs steel for its cars it
harder for them made it harder for them
and more expensive for them and earlier
this year GM cut its profit forecast for
the year because for that reason so that
rising interest rates there are a few
other externalities shall we say that
morning citing the slowing economy yes
yeah Lee gallagher's thank you Thanks I
mean last morning's are having me